[Musique]
alors moi ce soir je suis sous les feux
des projecteurs mais je sais qu'au fond
de vous les lumières qui brille
on a toujours tendance à croire que les
grands champions a quelque chose de
quelque chose en plus ou les grandes
entrepreneurs
mais en fait ce petit truc qu'ils ont en
plus moi je vais ce soir vous montrer
qu'on l'a tous en nous
on va plonger un peu plus loin dans le
passé
c'était l'âge de mes 17 ans
donc je suis aux États-Unis
et là mes amis se rendent compte que ma
jambe est plus fine que l'autre
moi je fais du basket je suis sportif
depuis mon plus jeune âge et on se rend
compte que oui réellement c'est plus fin
et de mon retour à Paris je me je vais
voir mon médecin et je lui dis
clairement voilà j'ai une jambe plus
fine que l'autre il faudrait peut-être
que je fasse des séances de kiné et là
ce qui me dit c'est bon on va faire
comme un petit des petits examens
donc vous que vous connaissez on est
tous passé par là qu'on était jeune ce
petit coup de marteau qu'on mettait sur
la jambe et boom ça se lève tout seul
on fait ça sur la jambe gauche mais on
fait ça sur la jambe droite ça réagit
même pas
donc là on se pose un peu plus de
problèmes je finirai et là l'IRM montre
que dans le bas-ventre il y a une tumeur
et cette tumeur en fait comprime le nerf
et c'est ce qui explique que j'ai une
lettre au fil du muscle parce que
l'information ne passe plus
donc là j'enchaîne les examens médicaux
je vois plusieurs médecins et puis je
fais une biopsie de cette tumeur
et là je me souviens encore bien c'est
de ce moment-là je suis avec mes parents
dans la salle d'attente et là le
l'assistant dit l'assistant du
professeur nous fait rentrer par cette
grande porte
là je découvre le professeur avec ses 10
internes derrière
et là à peine assis
le docteur me dit c'est un cancer
mes parents ça soit littéralement sur la
chaise comme s'ils avaient une chape de
plomb sur sur leurs épaules et blackout
souvienne plus de rien de tout ce qu'on
peut dire les médecins juste après et
moi je les ai regardés en face je
regardais face en face de moi ce médecin
et en fait j'avais
ce défilage j'avais en fait j'avais
comme si je n'avais jamais rencontré de
défi dans ma vie j'avais juste 17 ans
j'avais pas encore vécu grand chose et
moi j'ai vécu ça comme un grand défi un
grand combat que j'allais mener dans la
vie
donc du coup s'enchaîne les séances de
chimio
et à ce moment là c'est quand même une
période assez trouble pour moi
parce que dans des grandes difficultés
on fait un peu un blackout donc du coup
c'est j'ai une mémoire assez troupes de
cette période mais en quelque sorte je
suis je vis la nuit je regarde des
séries je sais que mes parents sont à la
maison ils m'écoutent ils sont là pour
moi et en journée quand ils vont partir
travailler je dors voilà donc une grande
partie mais ce qui me sauve c'est le
sport
parce que je donne à mon corps le moyen
de combattre cette maladie
il y avait les produits chimiques c'est
sûr de la chimio mais le sport m'a
beaucoup aidé mentalement aussi
et en plus bon voilà j'étais déscolarisé
par rapport à cette période là
et ce qui est ce qui est compliqué aussi
la chose c'est que moi j'avais pas envie
de voir mes autres amis de l'école ce
que j'avais pas envie d'avoir ce regard
de pitié qu'on peut avoir il est malade
ou cette gêne quand on voit une personne
qui est ben voilà malade en plus ce
qu'il faut se dire c'est que du coup je
faisais que du que du sport c'était mon
seul lien social qui me restait et là je
rencontre donc du coup je vais au sport
avec avec mon frère et pour la petite
anecdote en plus vu que j'avais plus de
cheveux moi j'avais l'impression d'être
Michael Jordan blanc c'était parfait
j'étais bien moi donc je vivais bien ce
moment là
et là le médecin il me dit bon voilà la
tumeur
a rétrécie plus trop c'est embêtant
quand même la chimie elle marche plus
donc il faut opérer moi j'avais mis
tellement de force et d'énergie pour
combattre ce cancer que je me suis pas
préparé à l'après qu'est-ce qui allait
se passer à la suite de ce cancer là
parce que moi j'étais sûr d'une chose
c'est que j'allais la vaincre cette
maladie
donc sur la table d'opération il m'opère
et là en fait on s'aperçoit que le nerf
il fait pas que comprimé mais que le
nerf il passe dans la tumeur donc du
coup pour m'enlever cette tumeur on est
obligé de sectionner le nerf
et là je me réveille je me réveille de
la table d'opération et là en fait du
coup
je découvre que je suis paralysé de la
cuisse droite
que j'ai plus de sensation et que du
coup je suis en situation de handicap et
moi l'image du handicap que j'avais
c'est une personne qui est en fauteuil
c'est une personne qui était plus
capable de et vous pouvez regarder dans
le dictionnaire aujourd'hui sur le mot
handicap c'est pas très joli j'avais pas
envie d'être associé à ça et j'avais
encore le regard des autres et très
compliqué pour ça j'ai 18 ans donc il
faut voilà il faut se remettre aussi à
ce moment-là à 18 ans bah on est à l'âge
où on a envie de s'affirmer en tant
qu'homme
et d'être handicapé pour moi c'était pas
ma fille
donc je fais tout bah c'est difficile de
l'accepter donc je fais tout pour le
cacher et là en plus le médecin me dit
une chose c'est que je pourrais plus
remarcher normalement je marcherai en
boîte en
et je pourrai plus jamais courir
moi ce que je me dis le médecin là ça
fait un électrochoc parce que déjà on me
dit pas ce que je peux pas faire
déjà c'est la première chose et je vais
lui prouver moi ce médecin là que oui je
peux remarcher normalement sans que ça
se voit et oui je verrai apprendre à
courir pour l'anecdote pour mes 20 ans
de mon cancer j'ai fait mes 20 km de
Paris et j'étais très content de le
faire mais j'ai trouvé que c'était quand
même très débile de le faire parce que
j'avais eu très très mal après parce que
de courir sur une jambe c'est pas top
quand même
et donc du coup bah voilà ce médecin m'a
dit qu'il m'a sauvé la vie mais pour moi
il me l'avait flingué
et donc du coup qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
c'est que j'ai utilisé ce mindset que
j'avais fait pour combattre la maladie
pour entreprendre donc j'ai beaucoup
entreprise j'ai fait mes études
d'ingénieur j'ai entrepris j'ai créé
plein de startups qu'on marchait en pas
trop marché mais
le truc c'est que à chaque fois je
faisais des choses j'apprenais des
choses il me manquait ce petit truc qui
fait que c'est un grand succès
donc du coup un moment donné je me suis
posé la question
qu'est-ce que moi Mathieu je peux
qu'est-ce que j'ai de différent des
autres
et là au bout de 13 ans je me rends
compte que quand même un truc qui est en
moi l'handicap
masingarité ma singularité
du coup aujourd'hui c'est qu'est-ce que
je peux en faire de grand
et c'est à l'âge de 30 ans
que je décide de me lancer dans un grand
projet qui est les Jeux paralympiques
j'ai pas eu cette idée là la lumière est
l'arrivée comment mais elle est arrivée
et donc du coup
j'entreprends tout là-dedans je me mets
à découvrir en fait quel sport je
pourrais faire en sport parrain parce
que on a vu depuis Londres les jeux se
sont de plus en plus médiatisés on met
en lumière de plus en plus les sportifs
par a c'est ça peut-être qu'il m'a donné
aussi l'idée que moi aussi vu que je
suis en situation de handicap et que je
faisais beaucoup de sport je pourrais
aussi aller faire ce faire ce rêve là et
c'est ce qui m'a animé aujourd'hui grâce
à cette singularité
donc du coup je découvre différents
sports je faisais du vélo avec mon ami
Benoît je faisais de la natation et je
faisais aussi du badminton mais j'ai
découvert le badminton comme on fait
tous à l'école
et c'est des opportunités dans la vie je
pense que c'est ça aussi qui me
caractérise c'est qu'il faut saisir des
opportunités être curieux et je découvre
qu'il y a les premiers championnats de
France de parabanington donc du coup je
m'inscris pour la deuxième édition on
est en plein développement et cette
année là dès que première édition que
j'y vais je suis champion de France dans
ma catégorie on SL3 donc je joue sur un
demi terrain simple et je suis champion
de France je me dis bah il y a peut-être
quelque chose à tenter après
je fais des compétitions internationales
et d'après je suis champion de d'Europe
en double et là je me dis babingo c'est
ça lance toi lance toi à fond dans ce
projet là
et donc du coup je me suis lancé à fond
dans ce projet paralympique et
devient un peu compliqué c'est que au
moment où
on veut se lancer dans ce projet par
olympique on devient pas sportif de
niveau comme ça je passe de deux heures
d'entraînement à 4-5 heures à
aujourd'hui 35 heures d'entraînement par
semaine c'est devenu mon job
et pour cela en fait qu'est-ce que j'ai
mis en lumière qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
c'est c'est ma jambe et pour moi c'est
ça qui est le plus important j'ai essayé
d'entreprendre les choses
avec cette jambe et ce soir en fait je
suis fier de cette jambe là et pour ça
et vu que je suis entrepreneur moi ce
soir ce que j'ai envie de faire de fou
c'est de vous la montrer cette journée
je vais vous la montrer parce que pour
moi j'en suis tellement fier
comme vous pouvez voir c'est pas très
répété ce qu'on va pas le couper tous
les jours
en tout cas j'ai beaucoup entreprise
mais j'avais jamais coupé encore de
pantalon voilà
je vous la montre comme ça
et donc du coup avec cette jambe
aujourd'hui qui est mon outil de travail
je l'ai tatoué aussi parce que je
voulais la sublimer je voulais la
montrer aux autres je voulais la rendre
belle parce que je l'ai caché pendant
tellement longtemps que je l'ai tatoué
pour ça à ce moment là
et tout ça pour dire que
au final notre singularité
c'est quelque chose de fort et dans tout
ce projet paralympique que j'ai mené
j'ai voulu mettre en lumière cette jambe
et
faire deux choses de grandes choses dans
la vie
désolé c'est aussi l'émotion
en tout cas ce que je voulais vous dire
c'est que grâce à notre singularité
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on peut faire de
grandes choses
et ce soir ce que j'aimerais aussi vous
transmettre c'est que
on a tous cette lumière en soi vraiment
et qu'il suffit de pas grand chose
en tout cas de trouver vous votre
singularité pour la mettre au grand jour
et voilà en tout cas si j'ai quelque
chose à vous transmettre ce soir c'est
que grâce à votre singularité vous
pouvez faire de grandes choses donc
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]